[Applause]
my specialty as a sex educator is I
bring the science but my first and most
important job is that I stay neutral
when I talk about anything sex related
no embarrassment no titillation no
judgment no shame no matter where I am
no matter what question you ask me
there's at an end of a conference in a
hotel lobby once I'm literally on my way
out the door and a colleague chases me
down Emily Emily I just have a really
quick question um a friend of mine wants
to know if it's possible to get addicted
to her vibrator the answer is no but it
is possible to get spoiled a different
conference is won in an outdoor tropical
paradise I'm at the breakfast buffet and
a couple approaches me uh hi Emily we're
sorry to interrupt you but um we just
wanted to ask a quick question about
premature ejaculation sure let me tell
you about the stop-start technique that
is my life I stay neutral when other
people might squeak squeak is an emotion
that combines surprise with
embarrassment
plus some disgust and like not knowing
what to do with your hands so if it's
and it's a product the reason you
experience it is because you spent the
first two decades of your life learning
that sex is a dangerous and disgusting
source of everlasting shame and if
you're not really good at it no one will
ever love you so you might squish
hearing me talk about sex while you're
sitting in a roomful of strangers that
is normal I invite you to breathe
feelings are tunnels we make our way
through the darkness to get to the light
at the end and I promise it's worth it
because I want to share with you today a
piece of science that has changed how I
think about everything from the behavior
of neurotransmitters in our emotional
brain to the time
a mix of our interpersonal relationships
to our judicial system and it starts
with our brain there's an area of your
brain you've probably heard referred to
as the reward sent her I think calling
if the reward center is a little bit
like calling your face your nose
that is one prominent feature but it
ignores some other parts and believe you
really confused if you're trying to
understand how phases work it's actually
three intertwined but separable systems
the first system is liking which is like
reward so this is the opioid hot spots
in your emotional brain it assesses
hedonic impact does this stimulus feel
good how good does this stimulus feel
bad how bad if you drop sugar water on
the tongue of a newborn infant the
opioid liking system sets off fireworks
and then there's the wanting system
wanting is mediated by this vast
dopaminergic network in and beyond the
emotional brain it motivates us to move
toward or away from a stimulus wanting
is more like your toddler following you
around asking for another cookie so one
thing and liking are related they are
not identical and the third system is
learning learning is Pavlov's dogs
remember Pavlov he makes dogs salivate
and responds to a bell it's easy you
give a dog food salivates automatically
and your ring a bell food salivate bell
food Bell salivate Bell salivate does
that salivation mean that the dog wants
to eat the Bell doesn't mean that the
dog finds the Bell delicious know what
Pavlov did was make the Bell
food-related
when we see this separateness of wanting
liking and learning this is where we
find an explanatory framework for
understanding what researchers call
arousal non concordance non concordance
very simply is when there is a lack of
predictive relationship between your
physiological response like salivation
and your subjective experience of
pleasure and desire that happens in
every emotional and motivational system
that we have including sex research over
the last thirty years has found that
genital blood flow can increase in
response to sex related stimuli even if
those sex related stimuli are not also
associated with the subjective
experience of wanting and liking in fact
the predictive relationship between
genital response and subjective
experience is between 10 and 50 percent
which is an enormous range you just
can't predict necessarily how a person
feels about that sex related stimulus
just by looking at their genital blood
flow when I explained this to my husband
he gave me the best possible example he
was like so that could explain this one
time when I was in high school I uh I
got an erection in response to the
phrase doughnut hole didn't want to have
sex with the doughnut he was a teenage
boy flooded with testosterone which
makes everything a little bit sex
related and it can go in both directions
a person with a penis may struggle to
get an erection one evening and then
wake up it's a very next morning with an
erection when it's nothing but a hassle
I got a phone call from a 30-something
friend a woman she said so My partner
and I were in the middle of doing some
things and I was like I want you right
now and he said no you're still dry
you're just being nice
and I was so hey so what's the matter is
it hormonal should I talk to a doctor
what's going on answer so Rosen our
concordance if you're experiencing
unwanted pain talk to a medical provider
otherwise arousal not concordance your
genital behavior just doesn't
necessarily predict your subjective
experience of liking and wanting another
friend back in college told me about her
first experiences of power play in a
sexual relationship she told me that her
partner tied her up with her owns
whoever had like this she's standing up
and he positions her so she's straddling
a bar presses up against her clitoris
like this so there's my friend standing
there and the guy leaves it's a
power-play leaves are alone so there's
my friend when she goes boom the Lord
and the guy comes back and she says I am
bored and he looks at her and he looks
at the bar and he says then why are you
wet why was she went
is it sex related to have pressure
directly against your clitoris does that
tell him whether she wants or liked
what's happening nope
what does tell him whether she wants her
likes what's happening she does she
recognized and articulated what you
wanted and liked all he had to do was
listen to her words my friend on the
phone what's the solution you tell your
partner listen to your words also buy
some Lube applause for Lube absolutely
everyone everywhere but I want to tell
you a darker listen to her words story
this one comes from a note that a
student sent me after I gave a lecture
about arousal not concordance she told
me that she was with a partner a new
partner glad to be doing things and they
reached a point where that was as far as
she was interested in going and so she
said no and the partner said no you're
wet you're so ready don't be shy shy I
see if it hadn't taken all the courage
and confidence she had to say no to
someone she liked whose feelings she did
not want to hurt but she said it again
she said no did he listen to her words
in the age of me too and times up people
asked me how do I even know what my
partner wants and likes is all consented
to be verbal and contractual now there
are times when consent is ambiguous and
we need a large-scale cultural
conversation about that but can we make
sure we're noticing how clear consent is
if we eliminate this myth in every
example I've described so far one
partner recognized and articulated what
they wanted and liked I want you right
now know and their partner told them
they were wrong
it's gaslighting profound and degrading
you say you feel one way but your body
proves that you feel something else and
we only do this around sexuality because
arousal non concordance happens with
every emotional and motivational says
we have if my mouth waters when I bite
into a wormy Apple does anybody say to
me you said no but your body said yes
and it's not only our partners who get
it wrong the national judicial education
program published a document called
judges tell what I wish I had known
before I presided in a case of an adult
victim of sexual assault number 13 on
occasion the victim female or male may
experience a physical response but this
is not a sexual response in the sense of
desire or mutuality this brings me one
step closer into the darkness and then I
promise we will find our way into the
light I'm thinking of a recent court
case involving multiple instances of
non-consensual sexual contact imagine
you're on the jury and you learned that
the victim had orgasms to change how
your gut response to the case let me
remind you orgasm is physiological it is
the spontaneous and voluntary release of
tension generated in response to sex
related stimuli but the perpetrators
lawyer made sure the jury knew about
those orgasms because he thought the
orgasms could be construed as consent I
will also add that this was a child
being abused by an adult in the family I
invite you to breathe that kind of story
can give a person of all kinds of
feelings from rage to shame to confused
arousal because it is sex related even
though it is appalling but even though I
know it's difficult to separate those
feelings in a room full of strangers if
we can find our way through all of the
messy feelings I believe we will find
our way to the light of compassion for
that child whose relationship with their
body was damaged by an adult whose job
it was to protect it and will find hope
that there was a trustworthy adult who
could say general response just means it
was a sex-related stimulus doesn't mean
those wanted her liked certainly doesn't
mean it was consented to
lacking passion and that hope are why I
travel all over talking about this to
anyone who will listen I can see it
helping people even as I say the words I
invite you to say the words you don't
have to say clitoris in front of a
thousand strangers but do have one brave
conversation tell this to someone you
know who's experienced sexual violence
you definitely know someone in the u.s.
it's one in three women one in six men
almost half of transgender folks say
genital response means it's actually
related stimulus it doesn't mean it was
wanted or liked say it to a judge you
know or a lawyer you know or a cop or
anyone who might sit on a jury in a
sexual assault case say some people
think that your body doesn't respond if
you don't want or like what's happening
if only that were true
instead arousal not importance say this
to the confused teenager in your life
who's just trying to figure out what
even what say if you bite is MOLLE fruit
and your mouth waters nobody would say
to you well you just don't want to admit
how much you like it same goes for down
below brows i'm al concordance say it to
your partner my genitals do not tell you
what i want or like i do
the roots of this myth are deep and they
are entangled with some very dark forces
in our culture but with every brave
conversation we have we make the world
that little bit better a little simpler
for the confused teenager a little
easier for your friend on the phone
worried that she's broken a little
easier and safer for the survivors one
in three women one in six men half of
trans folks meet - so for every brave
conversation you have thank you
Emily come up here thank you so much I
know that you do this all the time and
yet still I'm so grateful to you for
having the courage to come and talk
about that on this stage it really took
a lot and we're very grateful to you so
thank you I am grateful to be here so in
your regular day job I imagine as you
put at the top of the talk you get asked
a lot of questions but what's the one
question that you get asked all the time
that you can share with everyone here so
you don't have to answer it a thousand
times throughout the rest of the week
it's the question I get asked most often
it's actually the question underneath
pretty much all the other questions so
can you get addicted to your vibrator
please help me with my erectile
disfunction underneath every question is
actually the question am i normal to
which my answer in my mind is what even
is normal and why is that what you want
your sexuality to be why do we only want
to be normal around sexuality don't we
want to be extraordinary like do you
just want normal sex we do you want like
awesome sex in your life I think though
there's a lot of fear around being two
different sexually when people are
asking me is this thing I'm experiencing
normal what they're actually asking me
is do I belong do I belong in this
relationship do I belong in this
community of people do I belong on earth
as a sexual person to which the answer
is always a resounding yes the only
barrier there is the only limit there is
there's two one if you're experiencing
unwanted sexual pain talk to a medical
provider and two as long as everybody
involved is free and glad to be there
and free to leave whatever they want to
you're allowed to do anything that you
want to there is no script
there is no box you have to fit into
you're allowed as long as there's
consent and no one wanted pain you're
totally free to do whatever you want
amazing thank you so much
you are incredible thank you thank you
thank you